i'm gay but i'm not a fashionista
i'm gay but i don't really prefer hookup
culture
i'm gay but you wouldn't exactly call me
promiscuous i'm still not good at
talking to guys
i'm gay but i'm not interested in your
other friend simply because he's
also gay but i know nothing about
madonna or lady gaga not into britney
spears
i'm gay but i still don't know how to
dress myself i'm not into designer
labels but i don't like to brunch
i'm gay but i don't want to be your gay
best friend but i don't want to give you
a makeover but i'm not a gym rat but i
don't like the stereotypical cut body
i'm gay but i still go to church and i'm
religious but i've
never seen an episode of will and grace
never seen an episode of rupaul's drag
race
but i don't think i've ever seriously
z-snapped at anybody
but i don't like drinking very much i've
actually never been drunk i'm gay but my
main identity
isn't just being gay
i'm gay and i love studying different
languages and i'm in a choir
and i like to write poetry and i do love
a good brunch and
i do consider myself fashionable i'm gay
and i love using the word fabulous
and sometimes i do say hey girl and i
have four tattoos 15 tattoos
and body piercings i'm gay and i like to
shoot guns and i'm really into archery
and i love to hike
and i like to do parkour and i play
badminton three times a week and i came
out at the age of 18.
i am gay and most of my friends aren't
and i'm colorblind
and i have experienced bullying in my
life and i have bipolar disorder and i'm
also sensitive and i curse like a sailor
and i graduated valedictorian of my high
school i'm gay and i'm a filmmaker and
i'm an illustrator and i'm a writer and
i'm an actor
[Music]
and i'm a chef and i own a dog care
business a fitness trainer and i'm
becoming a therapist
i'm gay and i love love love cats and i
love dogs and i like pop music
huge fan of beyonce britney spears lady
gaga and mariah carey and whitney
houston
and dolly parton and christine aguilera
and yeah
i love barbara streisand and i'm a huge
comic book nerd and i love playing
pokemon i'm gay and i'm obsessed with
rupaul's drag race i'm gay and i like
the kardashians
love will and grace and one of my
favorite pastimes is falling into a
youtube black hole i'm gay and i'm from
great britain
i'm gay and i'm a proud black man and
i'm half mexican and native american and
i'm chinese and vietnamese and i'm from
the uk
in soy mexican and i'm transgender and
also two-spirit
and i like to show off my non-binary
male body i'm gay and i've only been in
one relationship and i believe in
monogamy
and i'm paulie soy yes
and i love body hair and i'm into the
leather community and i want to get
married one day and i'm also really
excited to be a father one day and i
also have a great relationship with my
dad i'm gay and i'm an uncle and i'm a
brother and i'm a son
i am gay and i'm an activist and i think
everyone should have equal rights and
i'm a huge feminist i'm gay and i
advocate for safe sex and because i'm on
prep i'm not afraid to have sex with
someone based on their hiv
status i'm gay and i try to educate
myself about the other letters in lgbt
and i want to see better queer
characters on tv and not just ones that
look like me
and i know that our community still has
a lot of work to do but we're still
beautiful i'm gay and i'm not afraid to
let people know
i'm gay and i love it and i would not
have it any other way i'm gay and i'm
really glad i'm gay
[Music]
i'm gay and i'm not only gay i'm gay and
that's just one part of me